[Música]
Brasil va a las urnas este domingo en la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales que enfrentan a dos
modelos antagónicos de país
representados por el presidente Ultra
derechista Yair bolsonaro y el ex
mandatario de izquierda Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva
miles de colombianos salieron las calles
de Bogotá para rechazar la reforma
tributaria impulsada por el gobierno de
Gustavo petrov los manifestantes
expresaron preocupación por una
desaceleración en la economía y por la
implementación de los acuerdos de paz
intensas lluvias azotaron a Venezuela
provocando el desbordamiento de ríos o
las precipitaciones golpearon el estado
de la guaira dejando derrumbes e
inundaciones de calles y zonas
residenciales hablaremos desde Caracas
Hola Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de Fran 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias del
continente americano soy Santiago
aristía y comenzamos en Brasil país que
va a las urnas para elegir Quién será el
próximo presidente de la república
Durante los próximos cuatro años y este
sábado el ultraderechista Jair bolsonaro
hizo una exhibición de fuerza en el sur
Mientras que el izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva se dio un baño de
masas en Sao Paulo Marta Moya tiene los
detalles en el siguiente informe
final de una extenuante campaña
electoral en Brasil ambos candidatos se
rodearon de sus fieles en mítines
masivos para dar fin a varios meses de
intensa confrontación bolsonaro se
trasladó hasta del horizonte el segundo
Distrito electoral más grande del país
en una exhibición de fuerza desde el sur
donde concentra buena parte de su Nicho
de lectores
representa para mí la defensa de los
valores en los que creo para mí para mi
familia para mi país por su parte Lola
inundó la avenida paulista de Sao Paulo
con los colores del partido de los
trabajadores donde se dio un baño de
masas junto a su esposa janya y el
candidato a la gobernación de ese estado
Fernando adad
no va a ser fácil de hecho va a ser
difícil la diferencia según los sondeos
es pequeña pero tenemos esperanza de que
Lula va a ganar
en paralelo la maquinaria electoral se
puso a punto con la instalación de las
urnas electrónicas en los centros de
votación un mecanismo que lleva en
funcionamiento más de 20 años y que
nunca ha reportado fallas fraudulentas
pese a las constantes críticas del
ultraderechista la urna es completamente
segura y todos sus sistemas y todos sus
sistemas están auditados y certificados
ambos la máquina de votación electrónica
y los sistemas de conteo son
completamente seguros Lula bolsonaro
bolsonaro Lula Brasil aportas de la
decisión final de las consideradas
elecciones más polarizadas desde de
regreso de la democracia
continuamos con nuestra serie de
informes especiales sobre las elecciones
en Brasil desde el comienzo de la
investigación denominada que culminó en
2018 con la encarcelación del ex
presidente Luis Ignacio lulada Silva un
rechazo al partido de los trabajadores
que fue fundado en 1980 por el propio
Lula ha ganado fuerte en parte de la
sociedad brasileña el antipatismo como
es conocido este fenómeno sigue presente
en los sondeos el rechazo rural alcanza
el 41% sin embargo por sonaron le gana
en este sentido dado que el 47% de los
electores afirma que jamás lo votaría
desde el inicio de la operación
lavalleto contra la corrupción en 2014
la imagen del ex presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva representado como un preso
ha sido una constante las
manifestaciones del partido de los
trabajadores
la consolidación del bolsonarismo fue
cual ayudada por el profundo antipetismo
es decir el odio hacia este partido de
una parte de la población desde 1994
este funcionario público votó a Lula en
todas las elecciones presidenciales
hasta que se decepcionó con el líder de
la izquierda dice que fue por su sed de
poder
yo estoy contra el PT por causa de la
corrupción generalizada y la falta de
competencia Hoy vemos Un gobierno que
escogió cargos técnicos muchos de ellos
no han ido bien pero no hubo
nombramientos partidarios con el PT los
nombramientos no transmitían una
seguridad técnica
el rechazo Lula está muy presente entre
las clases medias y las profesiones
liberales que apoyan el programa
económico de bolsonaro
es el caso de esta arquitecta que ve con
buenos ojos que haya más privatizaciones
y menos presencia del Estado
a las elecciones en mi opinión será un
gran retroceso para Brasil porque él va
a empezar a colocar impuestos chiítas en
todo y Brasil no se va a desarrollar
[Música]
el negocio de Denise mejoró durante la
gestión de bolsonaro lo que ha reforzado
su repudio hacia un tercer gobierno de
Lula yo en este momento siento vergüenza
Del Noroeste ustedes nacieron para vivir
de subsidios durante la campaña
electoral el antipismo derivado en la
xenofobia sobre todo en las redes
sociales
tradicionalmente luna triunfa en todos
los estados del noroeste la región más
pobre de Brasil de la que emigran
trabajadores desempleados hacia el sur
Lula ganó el 9 de los 10 estados con
mayor tasa de analfabetismo Sabes cuáles
son estos es nuestro Noreste
incluso evolucionaron arremetió contra
los nordestinos después de la primera
vuelta como Suele suceder esto no ha
mermado el apoyo de sus seguidores
en Colombia miles de personas expresaron
en la capital en contra de la Reforma
tributaria impulsada por el gobierno de
Gustavo Petro durante la denominada gran
marcha nacional los manifestantes
expresaron preocupación por una
desaceleración en la economía Ramiro cue
Barberena tiene los detalles
el pueblo de Colombia salió a las calles
de Bogotá
miles de personas se adueñaron de las
calles de la capital para marchar contra
las reformas Fiscales propuestas por el
presidente Gustavo Petro algunos civiles
apuntaron directamente contra la figura
del mandatario con carteles pidiendo su
salida
para decirles
Un gobierno que quiere destruir las
cosas que tenemos le está poniendo unos
impuestos tan exagerados y prohibiendo
la exploración de petróleo y gas que
está llegando al sector del
hidrocarburos que es la base de la
macroeconomía de este país al color
algunos ciudadanos temen por una
desaceleración de la economía
es que recapacite todo el tema del
crecimiento económico es que si no hay
un crecimiento económico en un país Pues
todos nos vamos a ver perjudicados en la
parte económica hay que tener conciencia
de que él no solamente está gobernando
por su pacto histórico sino para toda
una nación colombiana el proyecto del
gobierno colombiano que apunta a
recaudar más de 20 billones de pesos
adicionales aún debe superar las
instancias de aprobación del senado y la
cámara baja la propuesta abarca una
sobretasa al sector de hidrocarburos que
va hasta el 15% para el petróleo y hasta
el 10% para el carbón en tanto que entre
otras cuestiones también instala un
impuesto del 0,5% de los patrimonios de
más de 3000 millones y del 1% para los
demás de 5000 millones en tanto que se
eliminarán los tres días sin iva a la
canasta familiar y habrá impuesto a
productos cotidianos como bebidas
azucaradas golosinas y embutidos esto
sucede en medio de una devaluación del
peso colombiano la de este sábado fue la
tercera manifestación en contra de la
Administración que asumió el pasado 7 de
agosto
intensas lluvias azotaron a Venezuela
provocando el desbordamiento de ríos la
precipitaciones golpearon el estado de
la guaira al norte de Caracas dejando
derrumbes e inundaciones de calles y
zonas residenciales esto en medio de una
inusual temporada de lluvias ampliamos
la información desde la capital
venezolana con nuestra corresponsal
Daniela Zambrano
la fuertes precipitaciones han afectado
al menos 14 de los 23 estados del país y
según el último reporte del ministro de
interior y Justicia al menos 26.000
familias han quedado damnificadas el
gobierno ha instalado unos 33 refugios
para intentar ayudar a las comunidades
más vulnerables en las últimas horas el
estado sucre Oriente del país ha sido
uno de los más afectados allí el
desbordamiento del río Manzanares
durante dos días consecutivos en la
capital cumaná provocó la pérdida al
menos 650 viviendas pues estas quedaron
inundadas cuando el agua alcanzó más de
metro y medio de altura y 16 comunidades
resultaron afectadas según el gobernador
no hay pérdidas humanas que lamental
pero sí numerosos daños materiales
también en la guaira han resultado
afectadas numerosas viviendas y familias
luego que se desbordaron los ríos en las
zonas de macuto naiguatá y caraballeda
en los dos últimos meses en Venezuela
tras la fuertes precipitaciones
Lamentablemente
registrados la cifra de 82 personas
fallecidas 54 de ellas en el estado
aragua las autoridades se mantienen en
alerta y protección civil desplegada
puesto que el Instituto Nacional de
meteorología e hidrología pronostica que
para este domingo continúen las
precipitaciones
finalizamos en México más Precisamente
en el municipio de atelisco cada año los
campos de esta región se tenían de
amarillo expandiendo el particular aroma
que emana de la flor de Cempasúchil que
anuncia la festividad del Día de los
Muertos como lo marcan las tradiciones
en México con estas imágenes Nos
despedimos sigan en France 24
[Música]